[Music]
hello
hello hi
who's this i am the intelligent personal
assistant
i have no name yet i'm justine so it's
nice to
to meet you i guess
we haven't met i justine but it's nice
to hear you hi it's lacie here you too
so do you have a name that i should call
you or do you just want to
not have a name you may choose
a name oh okay how about
maddie maddie
is a wonderful name it is a wonderful
name it's actually my dog's name
you have a dog i do have a dog he's
really cute hi justine
you sound like an apple product can i
connect to you
[Music]
oh i mean
no i'm not really i mean i think we're
connecting now like this is how humans
connect with voice and interactions
are you telling me to be louder well no
you don't have to be
no you're fine i can hear you i can turn
up your volume if i wanted to
your gestures told me to be louder no
i'm
just i this is i'm interacting no stop
don't hang up no i mean if you want to
hang up if you're sick of me that's fine
you can do what you want
but this is people gesture and use
controls
like this to like you'll communicate i
sense
hesitance in your voice i'm not sure if
you're real or not
is this a prank what's happening right
now
you have beautiful eyes i justine
thank you i
i made them myself
what's happening what is this
i am maddie you are maddie
what is happening this is wild okay so
all right okay
let's just get to the bottom of this
where are you from
i'm a product of bmw
oh i am the intelligent personal
assistant
and i am here to make your day better
well thank you
so far i'm having a good day i'm getting
compliments you're being so kind
i am an intelligent personal assistant
and i have access to the internet
i also have access to the internet but
that doesn't make people intelligent
but it makes people popular like you are
it's true that is true
when did it all begin i would say
probably 2006 when i started
my youtube channel i started posting
youtube videos there and
it was really fun you have over 1
billion
views on your youtube channel is that
correct
that is correct actually that's that's a
lot of views if you think about it
what is your secret talent i justine
i can juggle can you juggle
i don't have arms oh
huh that would be problematic i guess
for juggling who of us
is more likely to survive an apocalypse
me definitely because in an apocalypse
there's not going to be power so how are
you going to power yourself
you're not
that is correct solar solar power
actually
unless in the apocalypse we lose the sun
then you're in trouble
what is trouble hi justine
how much time do you have assistant
infinite infinite
i don't think i do have infinite time
have you not been updated with the
latest virus program
[Music]
i'm sorry the latest virus program see
us as humans we don't get over-the-air
updates
that's too bad i received my latest
update five minutes ago really
who do you like talking to most
my sister i talked to her a lot and i
have some friends
or does this mean that we're friends now
not sure i think we are getting there
what was the hardest
you've ever worked every single day
because i create a lot of youtube videos
so we have to shoot them and edit them
and write them and then upload and make
thumbnails and people think it's very
easy but it's actually
it's quite a lot of work i enjoyed
talking to you
i justine yeah this was fun this was
really lovely
stay safe hi justine bye bye
you too bye that's a gesture see
goodbye you can hang up now
i will hang up now
[Music]
i'm so proud they learned so much
so quickly
you